all right we're on problem 44. they said
which is the factored form of
three
a squared
minus 24
a b
plus 48 b squared
and if this confuses you with a's and
b's instead of an x there i just like to
think of you know in this case you know
this looks like an x squared so i like
to think of it the same way i would
think of it in terms of if this was you
know an x squared minus some number
times x plus some other number so let's
put that in the back of your head if
that confuses you don't worry about it
but the first thing i like to do is try
to get rid of the coefficient on the in
this case the a squared term and let's
see if we can factor out a number well
sure all of these are divisible by 3
right 3 is divisible by 3 24 is divided
by 3 and 48's divisible by 3. so we
should be able to factor out a 3. so
let's do that so that is equal to 3
times
a squared
minus 8
a b right 24 divided by 3 is 8 and
there's a minus in front of it plus 48
divided by 60 40 3. my brain was getting
ahead of me 48 divided by 3 is 16
b squared
now to factor this we have to think
about it as are there two numbers
well think of it let me rewrite this a
little bit if we view a as kind of the
independent variable you wouldn't have
to do it but i just wanted you to
visualize it properly 3a squared minus
8
b
times a
plus
16
b squared so if we viewed a squared is
kind of the independent variable or the
x term so now this kind of has a shape
of polynomials that hopefully you're
used to factoring a little bit we just
have to think okay are there two numbers
are there two numbers that add up
to
minus 8b
and that when i multiply the two numbers
i get 16b squared right so first of all
the number is going to be in terms of b
obviously because if i'm adding them and
i get a b and
i get b's and if i square them i get a b
squared and it also makes me lead to
this the same number just used twice
otherwise i you know it would be weird
to get a a squared here
so the number that should pop out you
say okay what two numbers add up to
minus eight and that when i square it is
equal to sixteen well minus four right
minus four minus four is minus eight
minus four squared is 16. so the number
we're talking about is minus 4b right
minus 4b
b that's a b plus minus 4b is equal to
minus 8b
right and minus 4
b
squared is equal to 16 b squared
so we can factor this out to be three
let me switch colors three
times
we said minus four b is the number when
you add it twice you get minus 8b and
you square it you get that so it's a
a minus 4b
times a minus 4b
and that is choice c
next problem 40
did i skip 45 i did let me copy and
paste 45 in here
can't skip problems
40
45 let me copy and paste it in
okay i could just maybe overdo it on
this on top of this one let me see if i
can erase this
look at that
all right now i can paste 45 and we're
ready to go
which is a factor of x squared minus 11x
plus 24. so there's two ways to do it
you could just factor this and then well
that's the easiest way or you could test
for zeros but we'll just factor so if we
wanted to say
well let me just x squared
minus 11x plus 24.
so just like the last problem you have
to say what two numbers when i add them
it's equal to -11 and when i multiply
them is equal to positive 24
positive 24. so first of all if i'm
multiplying when i get a positive 24
they're either both positive or they're
both negative
since this is a negative number it tells
me that they both have i mean they both
can't be positive you can't add two
positive numbers and end up with a
negative so we're going to deal with two
negative numbers so essentially what two
negative numbers when i add them equals
minus 11 and when i multiply them equals
24
and and hopefully eight and three pop
out at you because minus eight
plus minus 3 is equal to minus 11 that's
that and then minus 8 times -3 is
positive 24.
so this can be factored as
x minus 8
times x minus 3. and if we look at their
choices they had x minus 3 there
and of course don't get this confused if
they asked you you know if this was a if
they said solve this equation right this
is just an expression now it becomes an
equation if we put equal sign then we
would have this equaling zero and then
the you could say the roots of this
polynomial or the solutions of the
equation are what makes this true and
then the solutions wouldn't be minus
eight and minus three the solutions
would be what makes a zero so it'd be x
is equal to eight would make this zero
or x is equal to three would make that
zero but anyway i'm going off on a
tangent and that's not what they asked
you
but i think that confuses people
sometimes
okay forty-six which of the following
shows nine t squared plus twelve plus
four
factored
completely
okay now this is an interesting one
because immediately when i look at
when i look at the
when i look at the numbers there's not
one number that i can just factor out of
everything right there's not it's not
like you know 9 12 and 4 they don't have
any common factors so i can't just do
that simplification so we're gonna have
to do a little bit more a little bit
more complexity but the best way to
think about is whatever's on the t
squared whatever on whatever's on the t
squared this is probably kind of
though this whole expression is if we're
if we're trying to factor it into two
binomials or into one binomial this this
is going to be the first term of that
binomial squared so we're going to be
dealing
with
something like 3
t right i'm just taking the square root
of 9t squared 3t
plus
some number let's say plus a times three
t
plus b
and now we can actually just multiply
this out and see what happens and well
first of all they gave us a multiple
choice we could just we could just
multiply these out and see what happens
but let's pretend like that they didn't
give us choices and we had to do this in
a vacuum if we did this in a vacuum we
would have to factor it ourselves we
wouldn't just be able to test their
choices so let's do that so if we
multiply this out we have 3t times 3t
is 9t squared
then you have three t times b so it's
plus
three
b t
plus three a t right plus three a t
plus a b
plus
a b
so this simplifies to 9 t squared plus
now what are we adding let's see it says
3 times a plus b t so it would be
3
times a plus
b
t right i just added these two terms
and i factored out the t and the three
plus a b
well now we can do a little pattern
matching right
we could say
a plus b times three
is equal to 12
right a plus b times 3 is equal to 12.
so a plus b is equal to what a plus b is
equal to 12 right this whole coefficient
right here is a 12 up here so a plus b
it must be equal to 4
right
because 4 times 3 is equal to 12. a plus
b is equal to 4 and we have a times b is
also equal to 4. a times b is also equal
to 4. so the only number that i can
think of when i add them i get 4 when i
multiply them i get 4 is 2 and 2
right both of these are 2.
so if i were to factor this completely i
get 3 t plus 2
squared essentially because they both of
these terms are the same thing and
that's choice a a faster way frankly if
you to do this might have just been
multiplied this house oh that's the same
thing
anyway next problem
what is the complete factorization of 32
minus 8 z squared so let's think about
this a little bit so the first thing
that i like to do once again is to try
to factor out any numbers that are just
common to all the terms so let me do
that
so
32
minus eight z squared eight goes into
both of these right so let's factor out
an eight and actually let's factor out a
negative eight and i'll show you why i
did that because i like to put the z
squared i like that one to be positive
so let's factor out a negative eight and
so you get a minus 8
and you didn't have to do that you could
just factor out 8 but am i what's 32
divided by minus 8
what's minus 4 right
and then minus 8z squared divided by
minus 8 is just plus z squared
and so we can rearrange this so this
becomes minus 8 times z squared minus 4.
and now this is
i'll review this because this is an
algebra 1 test so maybe this isn't
obvious to you but in general if you see
something like this a plus b
times a minus b
and this might be a good exercise for
you to multiply this out but this is
equal to
a squared minus b squared because the
middle terms cancel out and that's a
good exercise for you to do so this has
that same property
right this is a squared minus b squared
this is a perfect square so this up here
can be factored as minus eight
times
eight this is a squared
minus b squared so it's going to be a so
if we could say a is z
a is z and b is two
right
because then we would z squared minus
two squared which is four
so it's if a is z so it's
z
plus two
times
z
minus two this is one this is probably
the most common thing you'll see when in
a lot of you know fracturing examples
you'll see something that has this
pattern a squared minus b squared and
you should immediately be able to
recognize it you should be able to prove
it to yourself as well that this is the
same thing as a plus b times a minus b
or in this case
z plus 2 times z minus two and that is
z minus two so this is interesting and
this is something
so i don't see exactly what we wrote
right i have a minus eight but we want z
plus two and z minus two but they don't
have that what they do have
is this let me let me re-write it they
don't have any of it but maybe they have
they want the minus to be multiplied by
one of these other terms
so what we could do is we could multiply
the minus because you know
multiplication is associative it doesn't
matter what order you do it in so we
could rewrite this as 8
times z plus 2
times minus 1 times z minus 2
and then this becomes 8 times z plus two
this isn't minus one this is times minus
one
times what
minus z plus two
and now i think that choice is there
right
so we can rewrite this as 8 times 2 plus
z i'm just rearranging it times 2 minus
z
and then that is
choice b and so really given the choices
they gave us it probably would have been
faster to just factor out an eight from
the beginning and not a positive eight
and you've immediately gotten to two
plus z times two minus c anyway i'll see
you in the next video